who you calling a bit bitcoin has all
grown up
i'm proud of you bitcoin because you're
all growns up and if you want to know
the truth
about the bitcoin craze all you need to
do is follow the money
let's talk money
bitcoin just pulled up a seat at the
cool kids table
when it recently reached a one trillion
dollar market cap
and there's only four companies bigger
apple microsoft amazon google
is now more like bitcoin baby the price
skyrocketed from 10 000
to 58 000 in the last six months which
is 350 percent
gains a 10 000 investment last summer
would now be worth 45 g's
and the question is why well for one
there was the pandemic
printing party 25 of all money printed
all time was in 2020 yeah
all time like ever and now congress
just passed another two trillion dollar
spending plan so
you're looking at five trillion dollars
printed in the last
12 months try to wrap your head around
that
that's so much money rappers don't even
talk about it truly they stay in their
lane with the millies and the billies
basically printing all this money causes
inflation which causes the dollar to
decrease in value
which makes bitcoin an interesting
little adventure
because you never have to worry about
anyone printing
more bitcoin bitcoin has a fixed
amount available only 21 million bitcoin
can exist
making it a possible hedge against
inflation without having to find a place
to store
some gold bars also with the current low
interest rate environment savings
accounts and bonds are paying
nothing and people are looking for some
real
returns this is a classic example of if
you can't beat them
join them so is bitcoin legit well
it's mainstream baby bitcoin is based on
blockchain
the technology that allows it to exist
bitcoin's mother
blockchain is a secure digital
accountant that keeps continuously
updated digital records of transactions
in real
time it's like the court stenographer
that is typing every single word
and some of the biggest players in the
market are using
blockchain microsoft ibm apple amazon
they're all using it
so whether bitcoin goes up or down
blockchain
is here to stay as for bitcoin the money
is
moving tesla pumped eight percent of
their portfolio
1.5 billion dollars into bitcoin and
said it would begin accepting the
digital currency
as payment square the company behind
cash app
moved five percent of their portfolio
into bitcoin
visa mastercard and paypal are all
accepting payments
in cryptocurrencies even freaking mr
wonderful who said
bitcoin was trash he said he's now
dropping three percent of his portfolio
into bitcoin and wall street giants are
getting into it too
goldman sachs is restarting its crypto
trading desk the oldest bank in the
country
bny mellon is making the leap into
crypto and jp morgan just posted 34
blockchain job postings to work on its
own
jpm coin talk about being legit
jerome powell the chairman of the fed he
said the fed is considering creating a
digital dollar
now imagine getting a stimulus check
from the government sent to a digital
wallet on your phone and then you can
use that money to pay rent
buy groceries even buy weed and don't
act like you won't
now not everyone is in on the bitcoin
bandwagon for a few reasons let's be
real bitcoin is more unstable than my
ex-girlfriend i'm sorry lauren
it's the truth the price of bitcoin has
moved by thousands of dollars
based on a tweet hedge fund citadel
securities founder ken griffin
said that he was not interested in
cryptocurrency michael bury the guy from
the big short he called the 2008 market
crash thinks it's a bubble
janet yellen the treasury secretary she
called bitcoin an extremely
inefficient way of conducting
transactions and she warned about its
use
and illicit activity and of course
hackers and the whole decentralized
thing is actually a double-edged sword
sure there's no government or individual
controlling it
but if things go south you're on your
own there's no hq
there's no ceo there's no 1-800 bitcoin
to call
for customer service you forget your
password to your roth ira
you can reset it you forget your
password to your digital wallet
good luck out there chief my two cents
follow the money not what the big guys
are saying but what they're actually
doing we know that major companies are
putting anywhere
between three to eight percent into
bitcoin
so you may want to do the same still
want to play but don't want to actually
buy
bitcoin invest in the companies that do
or the companies
that use blockchain but you're going to
want to have a horse in this race
because the financial system will be
very different
10 years from now and bitcoin is like
the future man
as for the other 90-something percent of
your portfolio
keep it simple my standard advice is to
invest
in the u.s stock market for the long
term stay the course
buy and hold baby either way you should
spend more time
learning than buying and if you're in
doubt
save that money
thank you for watching this episode on
the bitcoin boom i want to get your two
cents
on whether you're investing in bitcoin
or not let me know in the comments
section
below until next time save that money